since 2001 The Fast & Furious movies
have morphed into a massive sprawling
franchise in fact the series easily
rivals most comic-book movies a
surprisingly dense law outrageous action
and heroic one might even say super
aerobic leads in 2001 s the Fast and the
Furious we're introduced to Brian
O'Conner an undercover cop tasked with
taking down a gang of muscle car living
thieves who have been stealing what they
claimed to be millions of dollars of DVD
players Brian finds a lead in Dominic
Toretto the charismatic ringleader
robbed a group of car heads who may or
may not be the same gang that Brian's
after I live my life a quarter mile at a
time to make things even more
complicated Dom sister Mia the shop
owner of Toretto's market is the object
of Brian's affection Brian impresses
done with his driving eventually
ingratiating himself into Dom's team
which isn't a family just yet
unfortunately Brian soon learns that he
can only play both sides of the law for
so long and comes clean to the Toretto
family when it looks like dominus gang
will end up on the wrong end of a truck
a shotgun with Brian's cover blown and
Dom forced to leave town the two have
won last quarter mile race ultimately
rather than take his new friend into
custody
Brian gives Dunn the keys to his car and
lets him race off into the distance too
fast too furious surprisingly isn't the
second part of this franchise instead
that honor goes to the turbocharged
prelude for too fast too furious a short
film which sees Brian on the run after
letting Dom go free for some reason this
leads to a nationwide manhunt with his
face plastered all over the nightly news
that sort of thing tends to present a
problem when you're driving across
America winning street racers like some
sort of gear shaft version of Johnny
Appleseed when cops seize his vehicle
while Brian's driving through Texas he's
able to hitch a ride with an unnamed
woman who recognizes his face possibly
because of his uncanny resemblance to
Lance Harbor from varsity blues after
that he buys a new car wins more street
races and finds himself in Miami the
city where the heat is on in 2003 is too
fast too furious Brian is fully
transformed from undercover cop with an
unmistakable surfer accent into a king
of the miami street racing scene with an
unmistakable surfer accent
together with organizer and former racer
tej Brian's been racking up the bills
and notoriety in Miami that all comes to
a screeching halt when he's arrested by
the Miami police after they fire
electronic harpoon in
his car the police womp Lions go
undercover inside a criminal
organization and their wedding to white
Brian's criminal record if he can take
down Barone
Miami's resident drug lord Brian
recruits his childhood best friends and
ex-con Roman to help him race his way to
verone's good graces with the help of
another undercover agent Monica Fuentes
Brian and Roman capture Varon clear
their criminal records and walk away
with a pile of illicit ly acquired cash
and that's about when the time line hits
turbo speed with chronological hijinks
lows bandoleros with a short film
co-written and directed by Vin Diesel
that serves as a prelude to the fourth
film Fast and Furious following
dharmasya assembles a new crew for an
upcoming heist of a gasoline truck in
the Dominican Republic
Letty's back to rekindle her romance
with DOM but she's not the only familiar
face in the short film han originally
appeared and died three years earlier in
the Fast and the Furious Tokyo Drift
which was the third movie released a
quick line of dialogue establishes that
the Harn we see here has never been to
Japan so we know that this takes place
before Tokyo Drift but now though all
you need to know is that Dom loves Letty
the people of the Dominican Republic and
stealing gas from the rich to give to
the poor 2009 s fast and furious begins
at the heist planned in the Lowe's
bandoleros short Dom Letty want a go and
Santos steal a bunch of gas to give to
the people of the Dominican Republic but
their celebration is short-lived Dom
knows as long as he's a wanted criminal
let he's in danger of being arrested too
so he leaves Letty in the middle of the
night after go live his life one quarter
mile at a time meanwhile brian is
working with the FBI as a field agent
trying to find leads on a drug lord
named Braga tom is forced to return to
Los Angeles after learning that Letty
was seemingly killed by one of gragas
men while she was working with Brian to
take the drug lord down in exchange for
clearing Tom's criminal record DOM and
Brian both go undercover in Braga
street-racing organization
Brian intending to catch Braga Dom
intending to kill him while there they
run into him befriends Gisele Braga's
wonderous right-hand woman eventually
DOM and Brian reconcile and take Braga
down I would have won that race you did
she right
[Music]
unfortunately Dom is captured by the FBI
and sentenced to 25 years in prison for
all of his prior street-racing related
crimes luckily for him brian is youths
are going against the law to save his
friend the film ends with Brian Mia and
the rest of the crew teaming up to break
Tom out 2011 Fast Five picks up
immediately where fast and furious left
off Dom escapes from prison with his
family and the crew heads to Rio de
Janeiro to figure out their next moves
Brian takes a gig stealing cars from a
train but unbeknownst to the family one
of the cars they steal belongs to Reyes
a ruthless drug lord who controls Rio
with an iron fist Dom Mia and Brian
recognize that they've got a golden
opportunity to steal enough money from
Reyes to fund their fugitive lives
permanently it's more than a
three-person job so they put out the
call for the whole family to assemble
Roman tej Gisele Hahn tego and Santos
all arrived ready to steal 100 million
from Reyes
unfortunately Reyes isn't the only
obstacle in their way Luke Hobbs a
Diplomatic Security Service agent and
all-around tough guy was on the hunt for
the family along for the ride is Elena a
Rio patrol officer with a grudge against
Rios for the murder of her husband Domon
Hobbs have their requisite tough-guy
face off
this is Blas su but they're forced to
work together after Reyes kills Hobbs
entire team say for himself and Elena
the family's heist goes off without a
hitch
and Hobbes gives Dom a full 24-hour
grace period before they resumed their
muscular cat a muscular Mouse chase at
the end of Fast Five there were only two
things I could get the family back in
action the promise of amnesty and the
knowledge that Letty is alive it turns
out that Letty survived the explosion
back in Fast and Furious Burk got
amnesia
he was then conscripted into a kind of
evil version of the fast family led by
villainous Owen Shaw Hobbs on his new
partner Riley bring the fast family
because obviously only fast thieves can
catch fast thieves it wasn't that hard
to find you Toretto
was in hiding eventually through the
magic of street racing Tom's able to
convince Letty that she's being
manipulated by sure and convinces her to
join the team unfortunately she's not
the only double agent Riley's been
working for sure the whole time
just waiting for the perfect opportunity
to betray Hobbs it all
comes to a head on the wells longest
airstrip as a fast family's battle to
stop shore from escaping the secret
government technology Giselle sacrifices
herself to save hon sure stops and
ultimately the family's previous crimes
are forgiven allowing them to return to
Los Angeles once again after Giselle's
death in 2013 s fast and furious 6 han
finally makes good on his promise to
visit Tokyo in a movie released seven
years earlier The Fast and the Furious
Tokyo Drift
the third movie released in the series
Tokyo Drift was a failed effort to
reinvent the franchise without Paul
Walker Vin Diesel as most of the film
concerns itself was Sean Boswell he's a
high school scholar sent to live with
his family in Tokyo after his penchant
for street racing lands him in hot water
in the States
Sean meets Han whose call this ice
persona and street racing skills have
made him a major player in the
underground racing scene han takes sean
under his wing even loaning him a car
and tutoring him in the ways of drifting
to BDK the nephew of a Yakuza crime boss
you know what DK stands for Donkey Kong
drift King unfortunately Hans training
is interrupted when DK and his uncle's
henchmen attack Hans garage in the
ensuing chase scene Han is tragically
hit by a passing motorist and his fuel
tank goes up in a massive ball of fire
consumed with raging vengeance Sean
challenges decayed to a race in which
the winner has to leave town forever
Shawn wins becoming the new drift King
and Dom shows up explaining that
harmless family the post-credits scene
of Fast & Furious 6 returned to Hans
death in Tokyo Drift but with one major
bit of context a mysterious stranger
who's following the chase on a police
scanner with careful timing the stranger
speeds rights into Han and then as yet
names character calls Dom on the phone
as Hans car burns delivering a
foreboding message
Dominic Toretto you don't know me you're
about to there's nothing more important
than family in the fast and furious
universe the bad guys have families too
in this case Owen Shaw is a big brother
named Deckard
he kills Hahn in the post-credits scene
of Fast & Furious 6 when the family
hears about Hans death
Dom travels to Tokyo to pay his respects
and start the hunt for Deckard meanwhile
Decker's been busy he's already attacked
Hobbs and Elena to find out everything
he can about the fust family when Tom
finally meets Deckard their climactic
street fighters interrupted by
mysterious government agent named mr.
nobody
who needs Dom on his team to do some odd
jobs for them in return for the use of
God's eye a hacking tool I can find
anyone on the planet including Deckard
this time it ain't just about being a
fast
a team rescues Ramsey the hacker who
designs God's eye from a Somali
mercenary trying to use the device for
nefarious reasons
it all comes to a head in Los Angeles of
course where Darwin is teaming to keep
Ramsey away from Deckard long enough for
her to disable the God's eye fortunately
they have some help from Hobbes that is
gotta go to work
Deckard Shaw has taken to jail after Dom
beats him by stomping on a parking gary
side The Incredible Hulk and then Dom
Priestley dies and is resurrected with
the power of love
thus avenging horn the real-life death
of Paul Walker leads to the character
Brian's retirement as he rides off into
the sunset with Muir and their son after
going to Havana and winning a street
race by driving backwards in a car that
literally explodes dumb runs into Seifer
a cyber terrorist who blackmails him
into betraying his family for the only
reason he would even more family
Dom's ex-girlfriend Elena secretly had
his child between the events of fast and
furious 6 and fate of the Furious and
cypher is holding the two of them
hostage unless Dom gives her what she
wants nuclear weapons when Dom battles
against his family and mr. nobody
he calls in favors from some old friends
and recent enemies including the Shaw
Brothers who now have full on jetpacks
they all help Dom double-cross cypher
but unfortunately Elena dies and cypher
escapes to lick her wounds and plot a
future sequel Deckard Shaw arrived to
the requisite post-battle meal with
Dom's son who's named Brian after Dom's
best friend what's next for the family
coming in August of 2019 as Fast and
Furious presents Hobson Shore which will
see the eponymous Odd Couple facing off
against a superpower Aegis Elba
black Superman fast and furious 9 is
slated for 2020 and while there hasn't
been much news about it since an
animated show called fast and furious
spy racers was announced in April 2018
now with reports of onset conflicts
between series leads the future looks
cloudy
the spin-off might be a way to keep
Dwayne the rock Johnson and his popular
character in the universe without him
sharing screen time with Vin Diesel
whatever else is on the road ahead no
one really knows for sure all we can do
is get there ourselves 1/4 mile out of
time check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and at the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]